all right we've covered a lot of ground
easily a dozen performance rules yeah to
be honest it's a bit overwhelming
there's a lot to keep in mind I think I
can help you with that there's a lot of
different rules but really there are
three buckets into which we can place
most of them so what do you mean well
let's take a look first we talked about
minifying compression and caching all
three techniques apply to HTML CSS and
JavaScript next we know that some
resources namely CSS will block
rendering to optimize this we talked
about two strategies use media queries
on link to on block rendering and inline
CSS finally we also saw that JavaScript
blocks the document parser which is
something we want to avoid to fix that
we can defer JavaScript execution or use
the async attribute on the script tag so
looking at these can you spot some
patterns hmm let's see
minify compressed cache and minimizing
the amount of HTML CSS and JavaScript is
all about reducing the amount of data we
have to send down the wire right spot-on
that's the first bucket minimize the
number of bytes the fewer bytes we need
to download the faster the browser can
get the data and start processing to
render the page any other patterns hmm
okay so this one and this one are all
about removing files from the critical
rendering path for CSS there's the media
query stuff and for JavaScript we have
the async tag exactly there are many
cases where we need CSS and JavaScript
but they really shouldn't block
rendering of the page things like print
style sheets and analytics JavaScript
code are both great examples our second
bucket is to reduce the number of
critical resources right not all
resources are critical so I guess we
should pay close attention to CSS and
JavaScript in particular what's the
third bucket I don't see anything left
here right the last one is is to shorten
the critical rendering path length wait
what do you mean by length good question
let's work through some hands-on
examples let's construct the critical
rendering path for our hello world page
here at time 0 we request the HTML once
the response arrives sometime later at
the time
one we parse the HTML and construct the
Dom and then we render the page to the
screen note that there's no CSS or
JavaScript so as soon as we have the Dom
we can render the page we do have an
image in this page but it doesn't block
the critical rendering path that seems
pretty straightforward yeah fair enough
we'll make it more interesting in a
second but first let's analyze the first
page against our three buckets first how
many critical path resources do we have
here well there's only one HTML file and
obviously we need that to render the
page so just one yep we have one
critical resource on this page now how
many critical bytes do we have here
well the HTML five kilobytes so five
kilobytes right again we have five
kilobytes now the last one in the best
case how many round trips between the
browser and the server do we need to
render this page hmm I'm guessing also
one we send the request to the server
and we get the response and I think with
that we're good you're right this time
if the HTML file is small then we only
need one round-trip to fetch all the
data as a result the best case critical
path length is also 1 I remember
PageSpeed insights said that my page
should ideally be under 14 kilobytes is
this why yes exactly and of course if
the page is larger the page will still
render but if the file is large it'll
take more round trips to fetch the data
and this is pretty low-level stuff but
it can make a big difference in how
quickly the page takes to render so
check the instructor notes if you want
to learn more wait did you write a book
on this actually yes yes I did and it's
available online and it's free so if
you're curious about this topic you can
learn more about it check the instructor
notes
cool yeah will do